sans humour bonjour je suis très heureux
de tous vous voir
aujourd'hui je suis très heureux
d'accueillir les dirigeants de l'otan
pour notre sommet nous nous réunissons
un moment crucial pour notre alliance et
nous allons ouvrir un nouveau chapitre
dans notre relation transatlantique
les dirigeants vont aborder de
nombreuses questions notamment la russie
notre relation avec la russie n'a jamais
été aussi mauvaise depuis la fin de la
guerre froide
cela est dû aux actions agressives de la
russie et je suis convaincu que les
dirigeants de l'otan vont confirmer
notre approche double une défense solide
associée à un dialogue
les dirigeants de l'otan seront très
heureux de s'entretenir avec le
président biden avant qu'il
s'entretienne avec le président poutine
nous aborderons également la chine la
chine représente de nombreuses
opportunités nous devront communiquer et
dialoguer avec la chine sur le
changement climatique ou la maîtrise des
armements
cela dit la montée en puissance
militaire de la chine son influence
croissante et son comportement coercitif
posent certains défis en matière de
sécurité pour nous et nous devons
discuter ensemble en tant qu'alliance
sachant cela les dirigeants de l'otan
vont se mettre d'accord aujourd'hui sur
un âge à un agenda ambitieux l'agenda
autant 2030 tourné vers l'avenir
il s'agit de renforcer notre défense
collective de renforcer notre résilience
améliorer notre avantage technologique
et pour la première fois de l'histoire
de l'otan s'assurer que le climat et les
questions sécuritaires liées au climat
soit une tâche importante pour notre
alliance pour ce faire nous devons
évidemment avoir les ressources qui sont
à la hauteur de cette ambition
si nous
investissons nous devons investir plus
et d'ailleurs nous sommes en bonne voie
cela fait cette année consécutive de
dépenses à la hausse en europe et au
canada
260 milliards de dollars américains
supplémentaires consacrées la défense
depuis 2014 et je suis confiant les
dirigeants de l'otan devraient entendre
pour dépenser plus ensemble cela
représente un multiplicateur pour nous
et nous allons faire plus ensemble pour
l'alliance donc toutes ces décisions qui
sont prises aujourd'hui par les
dirigeants de l'otan permettront
d'envoyer un message clair d'unités de
détermination nous rendons l'otan encore
plus fortes et ce à une époque de
concurrence mondiale accrue
je suis maintenant prêt à répondre à vos
questions les questions inaudible
réponse nous mettons fin à notre mission
militaire en afghanistan mais nous
allons continuer notre soutien aux
afghan et aux forces de sécurité
afghanes ceux ci de par notre présence
civile avec une mission de conseil et de
soutien aux institutions afghanes
nous allons continuer de financer des
forces de sécurité afghanes que tous les
alliés en conviennent et nous pensons
maintenant à fournir une formation un
entraînement hors pays aux forces de
sécurité afghanes et nous allons voir
comment soutien soutenir et maintenir
l'infrastructure essentielle y compris
l'aéroport
l'otan va donner son soutien ainsi que
certains alliés des etats unis la
turquie afin que nous puissions
maintenir en état un pôle
le pôle qui est l'aéroport c'est
important pour l'afghanistan pour
nous-mêmes pour la communauté
internationale pour la présence
diplomatique et pour la poursuite de
l'aide et de l'assistance
oui effectivement la présence militaire
touche à sa fin n'avons jamais pensé
être là en permanence mais nous allons
continuer à soutenir de façon civile et
par d'autres moyens
encore une question inaudible réponse
nous voyons une sorte de schémas de
comportement russe agression corde qu'on
contre ses voisins des cyberattaques des
attaques hybrides contre la géorgie
contre la l'ukraine contre nous mêmes
contre les alliés ceci avec comme
résultat la dégradation des rapports
entre l'otan et la russie
nous en sommes au point le plus bas
depuis la fin de la guerre froide mais
nous nous adaptons nous allons nous
avons adapté et renforcer la défense de
l'otan avec des troupes
une présence militaire sur nos
frontières et d augmentation des budgets
défense depuis 2014 augmentation
continue nous allons continuer à
renforcer notre défense et ceci par les
différents des décisions prises
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de l'otan 2030
mais nous allons en même temps toujours
prôné le dialogue avec la russie
le dialogue n'est pas un témoignage de
faiblesse mais plutôt de force du moment
que nous restons forts nous pouvons
continuer à parler avec la russie nous
saluons le fait que le président buydens
se rencontrera avec le président poutine
la maîtrise des armements sera un thème
phare
la main le maintien du traité sur les
armements conventionnels en saura un
élément essentiel
je voudrais conclure en disant que nous
restons unis l'alliance est unie et
c'est le message que les importants
envoyez la russie la russie ne saura
nous dit nous diviser nous sommes unis
dans la défense et dans le dialogue
demain le message c'est qu'il y a des
opportunités
s'agissant de notre relation avec la
chine par exemple la maîtrise des
armements le changement climatique
il nous faut avoir un dialogue avec la
chine dans le même temps nous constatons
depuis plusieurs années une montée en
puissance militaire importante de la
part de la chine qui investit dans de
nouvelles capacités militaires y compris
les capacités nucléaires ainsi que des
systèmes d'armes de pointe
nous constatons un comportement
coercitif notamment dans la mer de chine
méridionale et nous savons que la chine
ne partagent pas nos valeurs nous
pouvons le voir par exemple pour ce qui
est de la répression à hong kong et des
technologies modernes les médias sociaux
la reconnaissance sociale reconnaissance
faciale est utilisé pour surveiller la
population chinoise et cela n'a jamais
été fait auparavant avec dans une telle
ampleur évidemment nous sommes
confrontés à ces défis mais ces défis
nous ne pouvons pas y faire face seul
nous devons donc y faire face ensemble
en tant qu autant et c'est ce que nous
faisons
la chine se rapproche de nous c'est la
chine qui se rapproche
la chine se trouve dans le cyberespace
en afrique dans l'arctique mais la chine
investit également de façon conséquente
dans notre infrastructure critique
essaye de la contrôler on a pu le
constater avec la 5g huawei et c'est
pour cela que l'agenda autant 2030 est
aussi important il s'agit de renforcer
notre résilience investir plus dans la
technologie et s'assurer que nous
fassions plus en matière de cyberdéfense
donc les alliés devrait approuver cet
agenda autant 2030
et il devrait également approuvé le
communiqué et rappelez vous il y à 18
mois c'était la première fois que l'otan
communiquer sur la chine dans notre
concept stratégique actuellement la
chine n'est pas mentionnée or elle le
sera dans le communiqué et à londres
dans le communiqué 2019
en décembre il y avait une phrase sur la
chine cette fois ci il y aura une
position claire de la part des alliés
sur la chine car nous avons pu constater
une convergence entre alliés ces
derniers mois est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que nous allons commencer une
nouvelle guerre froide avec la chine
et qu'en est il de la fameuse mort
cérébrale de l'otan alors il n'y aura
pas de nouvelle guerre froide
la chine n'est pas notre adversaire
n'est pas notre ennemi mais nous devons
ensemble en tant qu'alliance faire face
au défi représenté par la chine
s'agissant de notre sécurité
l'otan est l'alliance qui a eu le plus
grand succès au cours de l'histoire
l'année dernière l'otan a connu sa plus
grande adaptation depuis la fin de la
guerre froide et nous allons continuer
de nous adapter ce grâce aux décisions
qui seront prises aujourd'hui et je
salue cette occasion visant à ouvrir un
nouveau chapitre dans nos relations
transatlantiques les etats-unis le
canada et l'europe qui travaillent
ensemble au sein de l'otan
non
réponse je salue le fait que nous ayons
un président des etats-unis qui est
fortement engagée envers l'otan envers
une collaboration entre l'europe et
l'amérique du nord
j'ai rencontré le président bart hayden
à la maison blanche cette semaine il a
formulé son souhait par rapport à un
lien très fort transatlantique
je l'attends impatiemment aujourd'hui
c'est un message très important pour
tous les alliés
ce que nous avons vu récemment et ce qui
est important d'avoir des institutions
multilatérales robustes comme le temps
une institution comme l'otan dépassent
l'importance et le poids des dirigeants
individuel bon bien sûr je ne vous cache
pas que nous avons eu des discussions
musclées
ces dernières années mais nous
continuons à travailler à livrer sur nos
tâches nos missions fondamentales la
défense
la dissuasion et c'est grâce au
leadership des différents dirigeants de
l'otan que nous pourrons consolider les
gains et avoir une
une alliance qui dépasse la force une
force collective qui dépasse les forces
individuelles des dirigeants des pays
membres de l'otan pour la chancelière
merkel j'ai hâte de la rencontrer et de
l'accueillir
j'ai eu le plaisir de travailler quelle
je travaille avec elle depuis plusieurs
années depuis 2005
j'étais moi même premier ministre et
elle était
elle est une un personnage qui a
renforcé l'alliance à transatlantique
télé début réponse les alliés
aujourd'hui vont confirmer un programme
un agenda pour l'otan très ambitieux
nous allons renforcer notre défense
collective notre résilience nos
technologies nous allons travailler
davantage avec les partenaires y compris
avec l'union européenne nous devons
avoir les ressources et qui soit à la
hauteur de cette ambition
en investissant bien sûr davantage dans
notre budget de défense nationaux mais
je je suis confiant lorsque les
dirigeants de l'otan se rencontreront
aujourd'hui ils vont également entériné
une investissements collectifs plus fort
je parle bien sûr des budgets des
budgets de l'otan le budget militaire de
l'otan le budget civil de l'otan et le
budget d investissement de l'équipement
si vous voulez pour que nous soyons plus
réactif nous puissions mener à bien plus
d'exiger de l'exercice de l'exercice
nous ayons plus de matériel nous
puissions collaborer davantage avec les
partenaires nous ayons des moyens de
commandement et de contrôle plus
performant une panoplie domaine qui nous
intéresse le fait de dépenser ensemble
est un multiplicateur de force
le fait de vrais ensemble est un
multiplicateur de force
nous avons besoin de financement
supplémentaire pour rallier ce niveau
d'ambition accrue et nous nous devons
donc renforcer les budgets financier en
commun
merci beaucoup